are you vegan no good I don't think I've
ever touched a single vegan food in my
life except like by accident I usually
do like vegan food I'm skeptical of
these vegan desserts this is a vegan
glazed doughnut but you know I hear the
word Dona and I'm on board it looks like
a regular doughnut it doesn't smell like
a doughnut it smells like a lemon square
oh that's terrible it's gonna taste like
fruit loops to me I was having this and
you told me it was vegan I would not
believe it yes for the vegan doughnut
I'm I'm liking it
tofu vegan cheesecake yeah
it's more Wiggly than regular cheesecake
hey does not smell like cheesecake at
all hmm no it's really gritty texture is
awful like so mushy bread I could not
describe to what this taste is I can
just tell you that it's working for me
it's like eating a giant tofu with a lot
of sugar in it why call it cheesecake if
it's not gonna taste like cheesecake the
more I have it the more I like it vegan
snickerdoodle I'm feeling good about
these snickerdoodles these are so soft
they look like rocks all vegan desserts
look like dirt oh yeah it tastes gingery
these win it's mushy it's just not
working for me
okay should crumble and I can mold this
into any shape I want
vegan cherry ice cream it looks like a
regular piece of ice cream except it's
really hard there are little pieces of
chocolate in it smells like ice cream
it's really good that sucks
that's super fruity it tastes kind of
like cherry flavored bubblicious gum
knowing that it's vegan it tastes
fresher pretty thing I would probably
any dessert no matter what raw vegan
brownie looks like a brownie with seeds
in it looks like a granola bar nothing
about this screams brownie to me that's
delicious I don't like it it's doubly
talkative it is exactly like a Clif Bar
mushy texture seems to be a running
theme through vegan desserts I would eat
it again I wish vegan foods would just
stop trying to imitate non vegan foods
just be yourself
be whatever it is that you are
[Music]